[Musique]
le 10 octobre 2019 Paul elkarade va
devenir l'un des plus grands maîtres de
midi on va voir mettre un chèque
monstrueux et un chèque de 691 522 euros
mystérieuses il remporte la somme de 691
522 euros et l'admiration de nombreux
Français je m'attendais non seulement
pas à faire autant de participation mais
attirer autant l'admiration et le
respect du public pour ce jeune homme
atteint d'autisme asperger l'autoroute
du succès est tout tracé interview livre
autobiographique et même chroniqueur
dans les grosses têtes depuis novembre
2020 en fait vous me donnez les années
tu trouves tout si vous voulez
franchement les grosses têtes
aujourd'hui
on va dire le max
j'ai plus récemment les traîtres sur M6
je sais que ce vote nous n'aura
absolument aucune incidence sur la suite
de ton parcours un trait de Paul Elka
serait-il un cette semaine certains lui
reproché d'avoir critiqué vivement
Jean-Luc Reichmann dans une interview
accordée à Télé Star pourquoi serait
jamais avec Jean-Luc Reichmann cela fait
près d'un an qu'on ne s'adresse plus la
parole pour toutes sortes de raisons que
je ne dévoilerai pas une brouille
personnelle qui aurait mis le faux
poudre et qui oblige l'ancien gagnant
des douze coups de midi à clarifier la
situation j'apprécie toujours Jean-Luc
et je clossais ce débat en disant une
bonne fois pour scout que je n'agresse
pas les gens sans aucune raison alors
Paul et le karaté Jean-Luc Reichmann
êtes-vous choqué
voilà
alors c'est vrai qu'il y a un choqué pas
choqué parce que tous nos cuisses mis
comme ça ça vient un petit peu de nulle
part on sait que maintenant il est dans
la bande à Ruquier sur sur France 2
voilà c'est dans les grosses têtes
évidemment donc c'est un peu compliqué
est-ce que tu as les infos qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé et Florian pourquoi tu ne
coupes cette sortie ah oui tu as choqué
oui toi toi il est ainsi fait que sa
particularité c'est qu'il dit toujours
ce qu'il pense et il dit toujours la
vérité donc moi ça ne me choque pas
qu'il s'exprime comme ça en revanche
pour avoir suivi le début de son arrivée
chez Jean-Luc Jean-Luc c'était il savait
très bien que le tournage allait très
compliqué avec Paul et il a accepté de
prendre des risques et ça veut dire
d'arrêter l'émission qu'un pôle n'allait
pas bien de diminuer la lumière quand
Paul n'allait pas bien et tout donc moi
en fait je trouve que c'est dur ce qu'il
dit sur Jean-Luc mais ça ne me choque
pas c'est son avis et c'est Paul Paul il
est comme ça oui ça et c'est un instant
l'asperger c'est la version la plus
géniale la plus brillante de l'autisme
ça veut dire quoi c'est qu'à la base
c'est un autiste et quand on ne connaît
pas les autistes moi il se trouve que
j'ai vécu avec un sans le savoir donc il
y a un moment donné j'ai une amie qui
m'abri fait qui m'a dit écoute je sais
pas si tu as remarqué mais ton mec c'est
un asperger je fais amour ah et elle
m'explique et je fais ah voilà c'est
pour ça veut dire qu'il est sans filtre
l'expression des sentiments n'est pas du
tout
identique à la nôtre ils sont
spécialisés et brillant dans un seul
domaine après ça veut dire que quand
vous êtes la source d'affection pour
l'asperger vous devenez son centre son
centre de vie c'est-à-dire la personne
qui attire tout ça parce qu'ils ont
besoin d'un sentiment bien sûr il a
compris je pense que Jean-Luc Reichmann
s'en occupe méchanceté c'est un
animateurs
et les autres aussi d'ailleurs détestent
quand on les touches donc ça c'est des
trucs
aussi c'est pas tant pis il est autiste
bien sûr mais on va pas faire un débat
sur l'autisme
c'est que tout d'un coup ils sortent
dans la presse toutes ces phrases sur
Jean-Luc Reichmann Débo non en fait le
pro le panneau vous pouvez poser il y a
plusieurs raisons pour lesquelles ils
sont un peu fâchés il va pas voulu les
donner mais en vrai c'est
vraiment l'autorisation de partir chez
Laurent Ruquier sur les grosses têtes ça
Jean-Luc qui se prend enfin qui est son
mentor entre guillemets la très mal pris
la deuxième raison ce serait que
Jean-Luc a l'habitude de poser très
souvent avec les maîtres de midi que ce
soit Télé-Loisirs 7 jours etc et Paul a
fait des à poser plusieurs fois sans
demander à Jean-Luc de poser avec lui ça
aussi ça lui a pas plu et enfin il y
avait les masters entre guillemets des
douze coups en juin dernier Paul de
Veillette il n'y a pas été parce qu'il
ne voulait pas planter Laurent Ruquier
et ça pareil apparemment c'est là où
c'est parti au clash et aujourd'hui pour
répondre à participer à des spéciales
sur France 2 qui étaient exactement le
principe
bien sûr
la même chose que Debo mais sans tous
les filtres c'est à dire que en gros
parce que quand tu es journaliste ils
veulent media machin si si mais tu vas
voir pourquoi c'est que tu entends plein
de trucs sur les animateurs sur toi sur
eux il y a plein de trucs qui arrivent
et moi Jean-Luc Reichmann depuis que je
fais ce boulot c'est l'un de ceux sur le
sur qui j'ai entendu le plus de trucs en
gros qui
parler d'un mec hyper autocentré hyper
animateur non c'est pas vrai bah non il
y en a plein sur qui on dit ce genre de
choses ce qui n'est pas autant voilà et
lui j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
vous êtes pense que vous êtes un connard
je vous jure mais
je m'appelle pas ça
mais tu sais très bien que c'est vrai ce
que je dis franchement
je t'écoute oui donc
voilà je pense que ce que dit Paul
elkaraté est-ce que dit Débo
c'est-à-dire qu'en gros il lui a pas
demandé son avis il a un peu trahi et
aller voir sous d'autres cieux ce qui se
passait et Reichmann l'a très mal vécu
parce qu'il aime bien aussi profiter du
succès de ces candidats et de surfer un
peu dessus aussi et ça l'a gonflé parce
que j'ai pas pour défendre respect mais
ça peut être pareil sur je parle des
grosses stars je parle de la rue je
parle de leur enfantaine je parle de
Dechavanne oui si c'est pour dire qu'ils
animateurs sont souvent un peu
égocentriques quand j'étais plus jeune
j'avais été au studio 102 de la Maison
de la radio c'est à Paris pour ceux qui
nous regardent et il y avait de la rue
qui faisait cette discute et il y avait
un truc qui m'avait chopé en tant que
gamin c'est que à la fin il serrait la
main tout le monde il y avait des dix
personnes vous savez cette émission et
c'est vrai que au début le générique de
fin part et c'est à la main de la
première de la deuxième il voit qu'il
est à l'antenne de la troisième de la 4e
et dès qu'il voit qu'il est plus
l'antenne et que je dirais qu'il a fini
les quatre derniers
oui ça s'appelle l'animateur tu vois ce
que je veux dire
et on peut pas dire ça
j'ai connu un peu de la rue j'en ai déjà
parlé ça s'appelle pas il s'appelle gros
connard non
c'est une différence entre Reichmann
après voilà hors caméra ne plus serrer
la main la troisième personne ça
s'appelle connard cherche pas
le jour
qu'il faut régulièrement il y a des tas
de gens qui ne font pas ça il y a des
animateurs que je connais comme Brognard
jamais il se produira comme ça mais
peut-être que tu l'aimes pas c'est autre
chose
que Delarue c'est toujours géant de
parler parce qu'il est plus là c'était
l'un des plus grands c'était pas l'un
des plus sympathiques c'est pas très
grave je reprends sur Denis Brunner qui
est quelqu'un que j'aime infiniment moi
j'ai assisté à des trucs ou Denis
Brognard envoyer pétrole la personne
très salement et la personne
tu peux très mal tomber et je l'ai
défend pas
autre chose
que d'acheter une du pain dans une
boulangerie et ce jour-là tu es pas
aimable parce que tu as une mauvaise
humeur c'est autre chose automatiquement
hors caméra ne plus serrer la main la
troisième personne c'est une autre
attitude j'ai vu Reichmann serrer la
main de toute de toute une équipe de
de rester avec les gens parce qu'il
était passionné donc on a tous des
contre-exemple mais alors attends Sophie
et puis et puis Jean-Mi c'est vrai qu'on
a tous nos moments moi j'ai eu un fer à
Jean-Luc Reichmann dans une dans une
boîte ça c'est pas très bien passé j'ai
trouvé que c'était très mal conduit moi
j'avais mon ex-mari qui avait racheté
une boîte de strip-tease et dans cette
boîte là c'est pas très bien comporté
d'ailleurs il s'est fait jeter
un autre sujet parce que dans la vie
encore une fois dans la vie tu sais pas
dire que c'est un sale type etc mais ce
que dit ce ce que dit le pôle en
question sur cette affaire là
précisément il dit en fait que ils
avaient une relation de maître et élève
donc ce qui prouve bien qu'elle est
celle de domination quand même de la
part en tout cas qui a été ressenti tel
quel de la part de
zingue pas Jean-Luc Reichmann il dit
simplement j'ai pas vraiment d'affinités
on n'a pas gardé de contact j'ai
l'impression que ce soit avant de vous
laisser partir juste qu'on ressort de
base sur quelque chose qu'on ressentent
des bases sur quelque chose il y a
effectivement ce côté animateur tu
m'appartiens je suis crashman le type
est venu jouer dedans et tout ce que
comme ça à la cause
mais voilà et que on a déjà souvent
parlé de Christophe Dechavanne ici on
est tous déjà dit bien sûr un peu
bizarre qu'il avait parfois c'est des
gens qui souvent sont connus très vite
ont beaucoup d'argent et une grosse
notoriété ils sont entourés toute la
journée par des gens qui sont là pour
leur dire tu es le plus drôle bien sûr
les animaux et on va tout défoncer voilà
et le nom de l'erreur parce que tu
voulais parler pardon il est adorable
avec les gens qui l'adorent et c'est
quelqu'un qui est tellement concentré
moi j'ai déjà rencontré différents coins
de France par hasard comme ça et tu le
rencontres à Cannes comme ça dans le
short etc et le premier chose qui dit tu
as vu mes audiences hier je n'ai rien à
[ __ ] on a eu l'autre on est le 2 15
août comme ça tu me parles de tes
audiences hier j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je
suis content
Jean-Luc si tu veux entendre encore de
la grosse télé parce qu'elle est moi je
fais le concours des animateurs et je le
gagne
la première année où j'ai gagné voilà et
Jean-Luc faisait partie des gens qui
étaient animateurs et qui pourraient à
ce concours et on fait un tournage une
semaine plus tard mais il y a que la
vérité qui compte ou je ne sais quoi et
Jean-Luc tourne en même temps que nous
et il me voit dans les couloirs et il
m'embrasse salut Laurent comment tu vas
et je l'embrasse et il me dit eh tu as
vu la bande-annonce de grands animateurs
il est adorable Jean-Luc en plus je
l'adore vraiment mais il est vraiment
son perso il est passionné
dans la rue je te jure que c'est vrai
j'avance comment tu vas tu as vu comment
j'ai fait emménager
mais là c'est l'un des plus grands
et en fait on pourra débattre ça va
donner un gros dossier pour vraiment
qu'on court
s'il vous plaît un autre animateur moi
juste que j'ai fait hier s'il vous plaît
on conclut et je dirais qu'en tous les
cas on a tous un défaut sauf que lui en
plus il est là on est là donc voilà